[Music]
m
now both of you also do rookia is this
correct i
she has done it for a long time i do it
also seldom have you seen once somebody
has exhausted all the modern means
they've gone to the doctors not one two
but let's say you know three or more
half a dozen a dozen and they've tried
so many different things
and now they want to give this a try
have you seen those examples in your
practice that you saw that hold on
there's nothing that can explain this
now
in
[Music]
making sure that when we say qualified
that they're adhering
to the guidelines of the quran and
authentic sunnah
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
back for those who are with us every
week you know that we have an exciting
show prepared for you
and this week is no exception we have
two exciting guests in the dean show
studio and we're going to be talking
about
the quran now many of you some of you
have seen
so many different people out there
looking for the cure
and many people they skip over the
miraculous effects that the quran has on
the human body so we're going to have
some true life stories to share with you
example on how the quran has been used
as a healing in modern day time with our
next guest we'll be right back don't go
anywhere assalamu alaikum
wasallam
so from my right to my left we have imam
musa
and we have uh also sheikh noor muhammad
muhammad muhammad
and you are actually so the
author of a popular book that's known
out there in the world today
okay so this book most of you know this
book huh let's see this book al-qaeda
yes
so you're the author of this book
yeah actually the main author was my
mother's grandfather yeah and then i
improved and translated
in english and uh motorize it
uh and this has become pretty much a
standard yes in most of the schools that
teach
the quran yes yeah so let's get right
into it uh the other day we spent some
time together and you were given a
beautiful example
of a muslim sister a woman who had her
brother pass away
and she was just kind of in denial she
was in shock the chaplain came the
hospital staff they were trying to
contain her help her she was really
frantic shaking her brother's legs and
and then they called you the chaplain
called you
and from there you ended up you know
trying to do your best you know talk
with her didn't work that and the other
and then you just start reciting quran
yes yeah what happened from there for
the people that didn't get to see this
video
basically
i was called
almost like two o'clock 2 a.m
and the chaplain
said
we've been trying to reach
any muslim
or imam
since 10 o'clock in the morning but
we could not
succeed
so um i did not want to be in the same
list where
nobody respond so i might made my way to
the hospital in neighboring state
uh took me
around hour and a half
so i was there around four o'clock in
the morning
as soon as i
enter
she recognized that i was muslim
she
started shouting
and
saying oh i'm being waiting here since
10 o'clock and nobody respond
so i don't
i don't like to see any
muslim i'm no longer muslim and
please go back
so i felt
almost like
a handicap
can not offer anything other than
i remember
the word of allah
in surah
[Music]
[Music]
so
once i remember
i
decided my best option is
to
recite the quran
as allah said
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the conclusion the meaning of ayat
that the the word of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala the quran
has power of healing
and prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
alaikum
[Music]
that you should try to seek the cure
from two things or by two things
one is al-quran
and second is
pure honey
so i uh start
re reciting the quran
from suratul baqarah from the ayat
uh
yeah
[Music]
as soon as i start to
start reciting
the quran
in few minutes
we observe
that sister mashallah
getting in
peace
and tranquility
all the
think we had difficulty to control her
or the chaplain was trying to
hold her and control her not to let her
to go
and disturb her brother who was sitting
still in the lobby since 10 o'clock in
the morning noise up almost four o'clock
in next day
morning
so um as she was going and shaking his
legs
asking uh
wake up wake up
because she uh of course uh was in shock
within two months
she lost her brother
she lost her father she lost her mother
in the accidents so she could not take
that and she was in shock and was
instead of denial
so subhanallah the power of quran allah
you know showed us
including the staff of the hospital
who were trying since 10 o'clock in the
morning now is four o'clock next day uh
morning
that in few minutes
alhamdulillah she
was in peace
and turned quality and in normal state
and within 20 minutes we were able to
send her back to home
so so we can
manage to remove her brother to
put him in
appropriate place
alhamdulillah
as i
entered she was rejecting and was
screaming at me to go back
now alhamdulillah when she felt
the
peace
tranquility the healing
she received
from the quran which i recited
alhamdulillah she came the following
week with full hijab to offer her salary
in the masjid i was imam allah so
alhamdulillah that was very powerful
you know
powerful thing which we
saw
and the entire hospital
observe
how everything all the systems
modern system failed
where i just simple person
uh was in i was in my early twenties
uh
uh provided her with peace and
tranquility and
healing
with simple
recitation of quran now both of you also
do rookia is this
correct i
she has done it for a long time i do it
also seldom have you seen once somebody
has exhausted all the modern means
they've gone to the doctors not one two
but let's say you know three or more or
half a dozen a dozen and they've tried
so many different things
and now they want to give this a try
have you seen those examples in your
practice that you saw that hold on
there's nothing that can explain this
now this is like something that even
increased your iman you're watching this
person in front of you the way they came
in and then after some time one time two
however sometimes it's a long process it
can be you have any stories like this
that you've seen that you can share with
us yes uh one time i remember
same like i was in my early 20s
and
one of the
ambassadors of one of the most
wealthiest country
they have
some kind of sickness to their
child
and they they took many
hospital in in the u.s
trying to seek healing for him
but there was no any change
so the approach
uh the child's grandmother
uh advised them to find
some
half of who can offer the rookie
uh from the by the quran
so
they reached me and i made my way to the
hospital it was
children's hospital
alhamdulillah i recited the quran it it
was only
less than 20 minutes
in 20 minutes alhamdulillah
this child his situation changed
so
they
requested me to continue
for
for a period of month just to
have a healing process
uh so alhamdulillah that was another uh
thing allah subhanallah showed us the
power of quran
when all the hospital all the wealth
all the modern things failed
and is i was just early 20s having even
finished my
bachelor
was just half of quran and allah
subhanahu wa allah showed the power of
quran how the quran affects
and heal
and change this
state of
illness
to cure
so that was another
you know powerful uh you know
thing we
observe
this is before the last part
these are wonderful stories that we come
to know that really increases our iman
and make it strong
and
it's good that mashallah you're doing
this show for others to come to know
from imams like ourselves who have done
the rookia for and first hand experience
the benefit of it
sheikh talked about the young girl who
lost
family members and also talked about a
young child who suffered
so though there are a number of
different stories but to just to
complete the circle i'll give you a
story of elderly person who suffers
stroke
after having gone through the heart open
heart surgery within weeks he suffered
stroke which is very normal they need to
watch very closely and he is familiar
with the situation so he has put in his
will that if something were to happen do
not revive me and just leave me and let
me die
and in order honoring his wish as he
suffered his stroke
he was hospitalized did not recover
as expected so they said well he's going
down
so they informed the relatives
and relatives made their way on that
weekend
and the local imam was also called and
was told that that's it we are just
getting ready to say goodbye to him and
imam along with the muslims that he used
to go to the messes regularly visited
and said their goodbye and came back
and i arrived there
and i needed to do what i needed to do
so i did my own rook yeah and decided to
surrender retria scene
and before the subhana tala eddie you
would not believe
within minutes
situation began to change
and on the monitor everything is
changing
i brought
the health uh care providers to look
into it this is there's something
happening we don't know what's going on
we need to call the doctor on the duty
they call the doctor on the duty they
reported and gradually before even
doctor made his way to the
ward where the patient was lying down
sutures had drastically increased
gotten better
and to the degree then when i see that i
was very encouraged and motivated and i
continued my reading until the doctor
arrived and then the decision that they
had to call the doctors on the floor to
have the meeting to see what should we
do to change the status because he's no
longer at risk of dying literally we
need to really change the situation and
today to cut the story short for the
benefit of
our audience and time
today that person after two and a half
years almost three years now
still alive
enjoying his
life
visits to the masjid and praise in
congregation
once he thought that he has said goodbye
and his imam of local muslims is very
thrilled and excited these are nothing
but
the living miracle of the divine
revelation al-quran when it is recited
on the people and it is not beneficial
only to the muslims
but this is equally beneficial to the
non-believers as well i come from india
where their larger minority larger
the majority is non-muslims
muslims are the largest minority over
the 200 millions in spite of us being
over 200 million we're still minority so
what happens from the local neighborhood
women
bring their children after salatul asar
and wait for the imam and the mussolin
to come outside and to recite some quran
and blow on them and they return
with complete conviction that the
children will be cured and this is
happening
all the generations they always know
that if there is one place they can fail
if they fail everywhere they can go to
is the masjid and the masjid then the
imam recites quran on these individuals
regardless of their faith and color and
creed and cultural differences the quran
has same effect of cure
so have you now in your
time spent you know using the quran as a
healing
how do you distinguish between let's say
someone is uh has a gin possession has
the evil eye
you know how and if somebody just
doesn't have anything if it's just in
their mind like how do you determine you
know which one is legitimate which one's
not
the symptoms the signs
over the time you build the experience
and
when you start reciting the quran
you can see some sign
from this sign you can
distinguish whether it is
evil eye
or it is a magic
or it is simply
some psychological
problem
so sometimes it's difficult to
distinguish
because the symptoms are very similar
but over the time you build
your experience and you are able to uh
you know make your judgment
so
the key here
the more the experience you have
the more you close to allah subhanahu wa
uh the most powerful
outcome and the result
will be
as i said
uh
another ambassador approached me for
that he was shocked that his wife
was found with the cancer the breast
cancer
and
they asked me to
do the healing quranic healing so
subhanallah i did only one
session with her
and the second time when they went and
checked
there was nothing
did not find
any any sign of cancer
so this was amazing that how allah
subhanahu ta'ala you know uh have put
power in this book exactly as he said uh
[Music]
it will make the mounting to shake you
know so
those diseases were as just were not
exist
completely cleaned
another
story i
i visited one of the patient in the
hospital when i was chaplain
and invited him for come join us for the
juma prayer
and he said no i'm not feeling good i'm
tired i'm sick
so i said okay let's do prayer
i i started with the recitation of quran
as soon as i did complete some verses of
quran he jumps from his bed he said oh i
feel good please take me with you so
that was another amazing
story that uh subhanallah that he jumps
and asking me to please take me to
the uh
you know
so i can
join you in the prayer so alhamdulillah
this was also powerful and then i came
back and
was trying to feed
what happened
of course we have to
feed the report for each patient
while i was
feeding
my colleague
was
also
observing what i'm writing
because we were sharing the office
so
he made a comment that oh when
we
do the healing
according to our uh tradition
uh our patient even they become worse
so he acknowledged
that
the power of quran the power of quran
was amazing that he was amazed so you're
colleague of other faith yes
so
the key here is not like
the more specific verses of quran
it is more
uh
like how much attachment you have with
the creator
with the al-khaliq
so
allah
have put so much power in his uh book in
his uh you know as we know the uh in the
time of prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
a group of uh companion sahaba they were
traveling
and
[Music]
one of the leader of the
village
who even was not muslim
he got
stung with the scorpion
so uh they were looking they were
announcing uh is there anyone who can
do some healing
so one of the
companion he volunteered he said okay he
can do
so he
simply recited
and
the that leader of that
village
was cured even though he was not a
muslim
so
then
of course he offered the gift
to
those uh group of companions they
become different
whether to accept or not they say okay
we are going to come and ask prophet
muhammad
and they came and they asked whether
they should take it or not prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said accept
and
have my share from it so to make it make
them feel that is fully halal
nothing wrong and then he asked
that companion
how would you know that this fatih has a
cure
so prophet
salallahu to see that
he did the right thing and he uh
alhamdulillah
was
you know able to uh help this
leader of the that
city or village
and
alhamdulillah
with
suratul fatiha which is the first
chapter of quran
most of us as a muslim we know it and
it was the first chapter and it is also
known as shifa as well yes
by the way the surat al-fatihah have
over 25 names
shafiya kafiya so uh alhamdulillah
was
you know
simply with surat al-fatiha speaking of
sarah fatiha there is one more story if
you allow me yes please we talked about
spiritual i mean physical sickness being
cured from the quran we talk about
other
touch
also can be cured from the quran i'm can
be
clear from the quran emotional distress
can also be
cured from the recitation of the holy
quran we talked about physically
challenged hospitalized weak people
confined into the hospital beds
let me give you a totally different
example
i have been a chaplain independent
federal penitentiaries as well
and when i was a chaplain at that time
was much younger about 20 years back i'm
talking about
and have had to deal with the
criminals who have such a background
of very serious crime that was committed
against and they were put behind without
any bail
and
and some of those individuals was
masha'allah
six foot four inches i have not seen
individuals like this and over 280
pounds
with their lord voice and their presence
itself it's enough to intimidate anybody
and i being a young imam at that time
and very skinny walks into this so
anyways i used to go and
meet with them and have halacas at the
penitentiary
what happened was i received a phone
call from the chaplain
they said they have a situation that is
out of control and really don't know
what to do and it is going
viral that all the muslims
in the
penitentiary seeming to be taking up on
that one and they simply cannot calm
that down
they tried every single thing exhausted
every single thing and then finally
i was able to get there and as soon as i
walked we had to pass through about
seven different doors in order to get to
that particular floor and that had been
shifted to it as extra special security
cell as i was walking through
we were passing through the
cells
and they could hear the noises of our
footsteps and as we were working we were
talking also
so as soon as they hear the some sound
they make even more noise and to just to
you know express their frustration
but this time as this picture and me
walking through those aisles of the
cells and as soon as i could hear loud
noises coming over there but as soon as
i pass through the cells when they see
me
things are calming down so literally
like when you're dimming of the light is
dimming of the sound was taking place
and everybody was curious finally when i
arrived at the place where they really
took me i recognized that individual
that i just described about 280 pounds
6.4 inches tall
and
i said open the door i need to get in
they were all scared they said he's in
this state of mind he could harm anybody
and nobody should be close to him
and they try to convince me and then i
insisted that please open the door i
need to get in
and the chaplain the head chaplain also
then came and said that imam is
insisting to meet this person in the
cell should we allow
so the head chaplain took me on the side
and said that it's extremely
dangerous do you realize what you get
into i said i am confident let me in
i had them open the door i went in
and i gave my salam and asked him to sit
down
and
he is like
hitting the wall even with his head got
you know i didn't realize that even
beating against the wall brick wall
it didn't bring him calm down he was
very very very
overly
frustrated you could say when i tried to
calm him down he didn't then i started
reading suratul fatiha that's what i
just remember when the sheikh talked
about it
the recitation of the surat al-fatiha
brought that person completely down
and i was sitting on the edge over there
the little stool size
and he just sat on the floor
and it was very difficult for him to sit
on his knee
so he just settled down and leaned
against the wall and spread his legs
and hands on the side
as if that you have poor ice water on
him
he was so calm
and everybody was watching
it was recorded in the cameras and all
the chaplains the team wardens were all
watching over there
and they said after i come back
everything has calmed down as we were
walking out of the prison they said what
is it that you said we couldn't
understand
and i had
an opportunity and a great honor to say
proudly that i did nothing but i recited
the first surah chapter of the holy
quran and it is the healing from the
quran that has calmed that person down
that all authorities all systems all
training has failed miserably and allah
subhanahu ta'ala gave us an opportunity
to have the dawah presented the power of
quran recitation and heart heals
emotional disorder so ever since anybody
who have any emotional disorder
including anger management i strongly
recommend everybody nowadays every
muslim knows
read surah fatiha even when the child
does misbehaving if you have spousal
issues or any challenges with the
colleague or friends wherever you see
any challenge or emotional disorder and
anger
recite surah fatiha and you will see in
front of your very eyes how allah
subhana tala will perform miracles
subhanallah
so tell us
have you now had experience with someone
who comes to you and you've done the
rookia you've implemented you know
this way of healing but then people end
up getting better but then they go back
to the other ways they not establishing
salah in their lives they're
dua so how important is this now so you
have a force shield
protecting you from the attacks in the
westwas
of shaytan
what do you like to say to the people
yes of course
we should try to protect ourselves
as prophet
demonstrated and he used to also do to
the hassan and hussain
with maui that
and uh
allah allah
three time each and then he will blow
and wipe the body as much as uh
he used to do
to himself as well as the hassan and
hussain so we need to uh
also teach our children
the same thing and to
before we sleep and also when we wake up
so that's a free production also in the
hadith uh
reciting the
ending ayat of suratul baqarah
from lil lahimah samawati
the day we reside
we have a
production
from the magician and uh this kind of
thing
and it's a free
we we don't have to pay to anybody
anything
so always
preventive action is much better than
going for treatment
so we should
teach our children and also practice
ourselves
to protect ourselves
from shiating
those who are involved in magic and
things especially when we're going
for the bathroom there is a dua before
we enter
and for each almost each action
before we do we have a duas so we need
to memorize those
and try to take them seriously to get
free
production free insurance
by allah
so
many of us
that's where they were they go wrong
they do not
take those uh supplication those to us
seriously
so there is a great production in in
this uh
the dual muslin
of course it happens the people when
they are not offering the salatul fajr
especially
the shaytan
easy for for the shaitan to attack and
easy for the magician to
do their work
and
deposits them so
we need to make sure we offer the
salawat on time and take that car
and do us
known so uh teach our children and also
we should practice and
that way we can get protection from uh
you know
you know like uh right now sometime
uh i got a received call oh
uh
imam you done rookie of 20 years ago i i
was very good until uh so many years
now i have i'm experiencing is a similar
problem again so if we go and back and
check probably they were not praying
fajr or they were in a weakness state of
weakness
so again the shayateen or the
magic came back or they were like
praying again
so
it's again it's it was not me it is book
of allah the quran and
especially whoever recite the quran has
a good connection with allah subhanahu
wa a good relation so that the quran has
very very very like a strong power to uh
remove all those things and we know the
story of
imam ahmad been humble you know
he's he just said
he sent his show that uh okay uh tell
them either to run away from get out of
from this person or i'm gonna hit you
with the show sure foreign
because he was pious and very close to
allah and knowledgeable
they run away just by
hearing that they gonna get strike with
the shoes of muhammad so the
you know all those
in the evil they run away
and they try to repeat after imam ahmad
bin humble passed away to take his shoe
and say oh or you know or somebody else
chew on and saying with this repeating
the same thing
and it didn't work he said oh he's no
longer in this dunya
so uh it's
all
power of
allah and
the quran if it's done with full
faith on allah subhanahu with allah that
allah subhanahu with allah
is the one only who heals
not me not any other creation of allah
is allah
and depend on allah and follow the right
procedure
then allah subhanahu wa
you know we will see so many
stories i have and
lost mother showed me because i was
involved heavily in
rukkia
over the period of 30 years
so as
a lost mother showed me a lot of amazing
things
through the process of rudyard so i do
recommend
to our muslim brothers and sisters to
take the book of allah seriously
give the right of the quran among the
thing we are neglecting that we are not
seeking the healing by the quran
we we have more other things so we need
to make sure we are also
learning the quran how to recite
properly many of us they do not know how
to recite the quran properly and then
they cannot blame oh i i recited but
nothing happened so we have to give the
right number one of quran to learn
how it was revealed learn to recite the
way it was revealed as um
recite the quran with a proper tone and
prophet sallam said
recite the quran according to the arabic
dialogue so um so we'll will have
effective will be effective and powerful
uh also
uh ibn al jazeera said
it is a must
if you are not reciting
the way it was revealed with tajweed you
are sinner because allah subhanahu
ta'ala revealed and then he protected
until it reached to us
so we have no excuse we cannot say oh i
i don't find the same quran the quran
the same and allah protect it through
generation after generation through the
young children the memorizing everywhere
whether they speak arabic language or
not
so uh we have no excuse this is the
first right of the quran to
recite the quran as was revealed to
prophet sallallahu alaihi
with voltage weed according to the
arabic dialogue and also then we need to
practice
understand the quran and also practice
and give all the right of the quran and
especially we're talking about the
healing
we need to take seriously the quran and
get
you know
healing by the quran with the way
the sahaba and the prophet
taught us
uh before we conclude just a couple more
questions tell us do you think that
every
community every masjid should have a
qualified
quran healer araki someone who is
qualified in this area
to be able to
attend to the people's needs
of course uh we we should have uh you
know if we take the quran seriously we
should have in each region each
community somebody who's well trained
and qualified and also he's
the most close to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
so
people
instead of
going through suffering and pain they
can get
almost free healing
you know with
the book of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uh
because allah says
okay uh it is
it's a healing and prophet sallallahu
alaihi islam said seek the healing by
the quran and the honey so
we just need to uh
take it seriously did you say hanisha
yes honey i want you to
have an opportunity for the viewers to
see that yes when we are talking about
seeking healing from quran in the same
ayah we are talking about
from the same saying of rasulallah saw
the honey honey also is encouraged if
you could just take a minute to shed
some light on the honey and we're
talking about real honey you know 70 of
the honey in the stores nowadays it's
fake so when we say honey where allah is
saying honey we're talking about the
real honey yes so spiritual healing is a
sweet healing huh yes so
that's another thing where people go
wrong
for the rati the person who's performing
the rokia you know i would say we need
to find somebody who is really close to
allah subhanahu wa yes who observe all
the five time a day pray on time
preferably with jamal like uh pious and
colossal of hanover to get the
effectiveness of the rokia
the same way i would say for the honey
honey in the market is so many different
type of honey
the the honey
described in the quran as allah says
so
uh how a los panter taught the bees
to uh follow the procedure so they
produce and then allah said it has the
cure but unfortunately
the
many
type of honey which we find the market
is not the way the one is described in
the quran so when we say the honey we do
mean the honey which is
purely produced
by the bees with the same process as
mentioned in the quran that the bees
they go and eat from different flowers
uh from different plants different trees
from different mountains they go and you
know travel distance and collect from
the nectars and then
you know but without any intervention of
the human being like feeding them
water with the sugar and all this kind
of thing that become mix
so it's it's it's described in the quran
subhanallah in in in some detail
uh so the the natural
uh honey that's what uh you know is
being referred in the quran that it has
a cure
and just one more thing so
making sure that the rocky when we say
qualified that they're adhering
to the guidelines of the quran and
authentic sunnah so these aren't people
making up because you have a lot of
people out there some people who are
many shysters or whatever you want to
call them
people who are doing things and
sacrificing animals using jinn
doing all sorts of weird and strange
things
that have no basis in islam and then
people get trapped and they end up with
these people and then they end up making
the situation worse or they get swindled
and they get their money taken and so
this thing is very very important these
guidelines have to be struck and or the
guys taking you know women and doing
things with them feeling up on women all
sorts of crazy things have you seen a
lot of these things happen yeah
[Music]
as you pointed out is one of the most
important thing follow the guideline
follow the quran and sunnah because
especially
shaitaan is
uh
very much
you know working hard as he said
so many times he tried to attack us
while we are trying to do the worship
worshiping allah subhanahu wa with allah
instead of
worshiping allah purely with sincerity
he attacks us and twist our worship
toward him
so invalidate for instance sometime a
woman come
for healing
and
if she's not following the guideline and
the raki is not following the guideline
what's going to happen guess is instead
of getting healing it's going to be
opposite
like among the guideline you know
okay any time
a person may
become alone with the female insecure
place without third person without you
know and they secured themselves nobody
have access the third is the [ __ ]
so instead of ibada and healing is going
to be something else
so that's uh also
it's not like a theory uh if you go do
some case studies you will find a lot of
example on that
where the you know people end up in
different uh you know trap of shaitaan
so uh that's that's part of the
guideline and very very important
anytime my sister would like to get
healing no matter who is the person no
matter how pious he is don't stay alone
with them no
no touching no touching and no i mean
sometimes if you have some clothes with
the clothes or
you know
some some barrier uh that will be uh
the recommendation uh
so uh but try to avoid as much as you
can and have
yeah that's very very important because
there are there are cases you know where
the imam where those people they in
instead of it was a different thing yeah
so um
the the the problem when we don't follow
the guideline of rasulullah
then we become vikram of shaitaan so um
this is also has to uh in our
communities uh they
either ignorant or they
care less
they think the imam is like a angel or
like a prophet
so it's not the case
it's already
set the limit and the guideline
so that's one one of the very very
important thing that
the sister should come with maharam not
like
you know
there is there was a story where the
brother came and
and left his sister with the imam
and there was no third person at that
particular place then the next day there
was a lot of complain
so um you know
so we we have to be uh you know
following the guideline and also
there are people who just trying to make
money out of these things they have
nothing they have not acquired no any uh
good relation with allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
their goal is to just
make money or deceive the people or you
know so again here we need to look who
is more close to allah practically
you know when he praying you know all
this observing everything as
the guideline of quran and sunnah
so
the more the the person is close to
allah the more the effectiveness of
rukhia
okay there are people just there for for
to uh make money so we cannot expect
much from them because their goal is
different their procedures are different
so we need to make sure we
you know
stick with the procedure
of quran and sunnah and
do the
rookia
courtney to
be effective and also i would recommend
each of us do their best to learn the
quran by themselves and that's why we
have institute we have a neuroni
learning center where we offer uh this
is the nirani learning center yes uh yes
this is you professor muhammad
we have actually in online now so you
have it online now yes yes
online they can come and learn by
themselves and also make their children
we have classes for adult we have a
classes for the children we have a
classes for those who want to be teacher
those who are already teacher so there
is no excuse they can easily simply
master the quran by themself and do the
ruka by themselves to their children to
their loved one what's this website now
uh it's a
nlc
va.org
nlc we a dot org so it's a neurani
learning center what about this one here
says teach quran.com this is another
yeah also teach quran.com also their
website
so they can reach us info at
teachground.com
it's also there in the book the email
where can people pick up the book um the
books available in uh this is a
beginner's guide for learning to
read this is the first step learning
arabic language and the quranic reading
resultation this is the one of the best
starting point
so once they fix their maharish
pronunciation then can they can learn
the tweet and other things so
that will be the recommendation that you
learn yourself
and then inshallah you will have a power
in your
recitation you don't have to have
somebody else
especially if you are close to allah
subhanahu wa allah
you're practicing uh so um you will have
a power and you will be doing with
sincerity uh you know so try to learn
yourself and uh if you if you're sure
somebody's pious is not like a
money-making machine
then you can approach them for to help
you out until you are learning you know
so learning is the key
go ahead i'd like to just add and
reinforce beautifully what she has put
together and the question that you have
asked for our audience
what is very important is that this
issue is real
muslim and non-muslims face situations
alike they all are in need of healing
where they go for healing it varies
for believers they need to believe in
when some muslims even have modernized
here in america to the degree they don't
even believe in such thing exist and
they suffer the most that i have seen
and those who believe and try to seek
healing there are certain things that
they need to be mindful of they just
wanted to give in a nutshell one i
sheikh emphasized i second that very
much
the rocky has to be mata shara
he should be
who believed in allah and allah alone
and believe that only quran through the
divine revelation and with the
permission of allah offers healing to
these problems and only two quran to
offer healings
second while he is practicing his
religious rules and don'ts and
regulations the people who are receiving
on the end also should also follow the
same thing that is among the least thing
that they could do is they should be
performing five-time daily prayers
the salah has to be performed on timely
basis and
guarantees the protection
from many indecencies so what we always
required that they to offer if they have
not been praying up until now please
make a new ninja from this point onwards
offer your salah to the best of your
ability on time if for god god forbid if
you cannot then make sure not a day goes
by without you having said all your
prayers in the beginning gradually your
goal is to be able to offer your salah
on time and wake up early in the morning
for fajr and what's not
third
reading of the quran sheikh brought a
very very important point the reason i
wanted to reinforce this for our
audience is
that
many people when we ask them to recite
such and such they say oh i've been
doing it for years nothing really
happened oh i've done and tried every
single thing really nothing changed the
situation keep coming back again
you are the same people who live in this
time and age where we use these gadgets
you type email address which you miss
out one digit one letter you know that
it's not going to be delivered you dial
the phone number with missing one
digital change is going to the wrong
number
you have a thumb print where you open it
and unlock your phone if it is wet
it doesn't even read you have to really
dry and put it back clean it so you
understand the sensitivity all this
nature
how do you then out of nowhere become so
naive when it comes to reading quran and
you read quran the way you feel like
reading it
you don't put any time and effort and
energy in it to learn with the proper
pronunciation
and if you're not reading it the way it
should be read how do you then you
expect it to deliver its results so
therefore the work that the sheikh is
doing it is essential
quran was not received by us
in a written form
rather it was revealed to us on the
spoken words
allah spoke to jibril jibril islam spoke
to rasulullah salam rasool allah
returned pass it down to sahabah and we
received
and that is the word and the sound and
the pronunciation has been preserved
till this day
and muslims have a duty to learn and
understand and put an effort into
learning how to pronounce just as close
as we can the way that rasulullah
in his companion and revealed from allah
so there is no excuse for anybody not to
read quran properly especially when the
tools have been provided in the form of
by the nuraniya and i strongly encourage
do whatever we can we came from
different part of the world to united
states of america and learn to
speak the language to the best of our
ability as close as we can like
americans
so when we put our effort and energy in
it we really mastered this skill because
we felt the need and necessity for it
the same at least if not more muslims
need to feel towards the quran and if
they put time and energy in it to learn
allah himself i promise
that allah has made it quran easy to
understand and remember and that we need
to put together our heart and soul and
learn to read quran properly and when we
do this with proper pronunciation i can
assure you whatever little quran that
you have memorized and if you read with
complete conviction for any problem that
you are facing allah subhana wa will let
you witness the changes in life within
no time condition is that it is to be
read
by properly those who practice islam
praise salah regularly and read quran
properly may allah give us the fear i
mean
and thank you both thank you for
spending some time with us here on the
dean's show and sharing much of this
knowledge jazakallah height
and thank you guys for tuning in you
hear it go ahead if you haven't picked
up this book go ahead and pick it up
it's a beginner's guide to starting to
connect with the quran taking those baby
steps start taking them now what do you
got
waiting for you except returning back to
your creator and you don't want to die
in a state now that you've been
disconnected from the book of allah the
quran and the authentic sunnah the last
final messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
so we learned a lot of gems here today
make sure you saw the power of the quran
but if you're not connected to it how
are you going to experience it so make
sure you're connected to it five times a
day minimum in prayer in salah and we
got to go ahead and expose some of the
bogus people who are doing some of the
bogus things out there you gotta adhere
to the guidelines
and continue to get well grounded in the
dean
and we'll see you next time subscribe if
you haven't already and continue to tune
in here to the dean show until then
peace be with you assalaamu alaikum